[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels ich möchte heute richtig leckere
brownies machen ich habe vor kurzer zeit
diese nutella brownies gemacht mit nur
fünf zutaten und heute kommen aber jetzt
meinen richtigen brown muss also die
richtigen schokoladigen saftigen
brownies die ich immer gerne mache und
ich zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die
ganzen zutaten sieht ganz viel aus aber
es sind im prinzip nur grundzutaten und
die sind teuer und man kann es auch
immer gut besorgen
also ich habe hier 230 gramm butter 300
gramm zucker etwas was in der extrakt
hier habe ich 50 milliliter heißes
wasser mit einem teelöffel kaffeepulver
vermischt weil wir haben keine
kaffeemaschine aber ihr könnt auch
einfach 50 mm kaffee immer dann habe ich
hier einen halben teelöffel st 4 200
gramm mehl
ich brauche 300 gramm zart
bitterschokolade bitte nehmt der
auffahrt bitterschokolade dann 60 gramm
kakaopulver
hier habe ich etwa 50 gramm schoko druck
so buck feste schoko drops auch in sankt
peter und 200 gramm haselnüsse und ja
also ihr müsst auf jeden fall zeit
wieder schokolade nehmen damit es dann
sie eben auch richtig schokoladig wird
werde jetzt nämlich voll mitnehmen dann
schmeckt weniger schokoladig und
vielmals süß und es schmeckt dann eben
am ende nicht so gut geht es zuerst mal
die butter hier in einen topf die mutter
nicht hinterlassen
und damit die wir jetzt hier nicht so an
brent gebe ich da auch direkt den kaffee
mit reis und auch den zu kommen
man kann das ganze nämlich zusammen
schöne schmerzen und die der zucker kann
sich auch lösen und ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit nämlich schon mal die
schokolade imbiss laken gerade so ganz
grob und die nüsse auch gleich in die
nacht
[Musik]
ich habe das jetzt einmal kurz aufkochen
lassen und jetzt gleich komplett runter
gezogen
jetzt gebe ich die schokoladen stücke
mit rein damit die sich jetzt in dieser
warmen futtermischung auflösen können
und es ruhig jetzt einfach so lange bis
alle schokostückchen geschmolzen sind
ihr könnt euch jetzt schon mal die
salzgitter zu geben dann vergessen wir
das nicht und die war nämlich auch viel
mit rein
um löst es schön hier drin auf
[Musik]
jetzt völlig diese mischung in eine
große schüssel um damit ich es einfach
besser verrühren kann wenn ihr übrigens
keinen kaffee mögt können entweder
weglassen aber ich finde man schmeckt es
hier gar nicht so raus also es versteckt
so ein bisschen diesem schokoladen
geschmack und das aroma aber so richtig
den kaffeegeschmack kriegt man
eigentlich nicht raus von daher finde
ich kam aus aurich drin lassen jetzt
ruhig auch direkt das kakaopulver mit
rein und rührt es um ihr seht auch mal
braucht es dafür gar keine besonderen
werkzeuge einer küchenmaschine
wenn ihr aber natürlich die kenwood habt
die hat ja diese hitze funktion da
könnte das auch einfach in der kenwood
alles zu lassen also bei etwa 60 grad
alle zutaten rein die man jetzt eben auf
dem herd hatten und dann könnte das auch
dafür rühren in dieser extra schüssel
kühles ganze natürlich auch schneller ab
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch nicht in
den topf gelassen und geht jetzt die
eier noch mit dazu eins nach dem anderen
also immer so ein bisschen unterrühren
und dann das nächste ein
[Musik]
jetzt noch das mehl mit rein schön
verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich zum schluss noch die
nüsse mit rein und die schokostückchen
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen da am besten den pikes aber
da geht's einfach
[Musik]
und wenn er jetzt sagt ihr habt eine
allergie gegen haseln ist zum beispiel
könnte die weglassen
wobei ich sehe in dem teig richtig
lecker findet vor allem weil ich so
etwas grob gelassen habe aber wir können
zum beispiel auch mandeln benutzen oder
einfach eine andere zutat die so ein
bisschen knackiger ist wo er ist
wirklich einfach ganz weg so und jetzt
fühle ich diesen tag eben meine frau
bereitete form
ich habe jetzt hier wieder meinen
eckigen back rahmen habe ich ein
backpapier twitter das ist hier so ein
bisschen ein
das kann man dann auch ganz gut wir
haben wir zu kleinen nadeln festmachen
dass mit klammern nicht ganz so genau
das aber dann verwirklicht dieser rahmen
ist auch nicht wenn ich das 1 5
[Musik]
und den bug kam habe ich übrigens auf
die kleinste größe eingestellt dass
dürfen jetzt so etwa 20 x 30 cm sein
und da fühle ich jetzt diesen leckeren
schokoladigen teil hinein und dann kommt
das ganze im backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für ungefähr 25 minuten
und bei der stäbchen probe ist es so die
mache ich trotzdem aber es darf zum
schluss ein bisschen noch was an den
stäbchen dran kleben
denn die brownies sonja nicht trocken
werden
[Musik]
die braun ist sind jetzt fertig und ich
zeige euch mal bei der stäbchen probe
wie es da aussieht und zwar bleibt da
einfach unten noch so ein bisschen was
hängen jetzt war das halte vorführeffekt
hier bleibt so ein bisschen was hängen
und es ist auch ganz gut so dann werden
sie nämlich nicht trocken und ich habe
jetzt so etwa fünf minuten abkühlen
lassen und jetzt bereite ich noch
schnell den gusto und dafür brauche ich
nur drei zutaten und zwar habe ich hier
20 gramm kakaopulver 40 gramm
puderzucker und 35 milliliter wasser
das verriet jetzt eigentlich auch hier
ganz gut miteinander geht ganz schnell
und ich finde das macht hatte halt diese
brownies noch so richtig schokoladig und
saftig und ihr könnt sie zwar auch schon
so lassen
aber ich finde mit dem guss schmecken
sehr einfach noch besser es wird kurz
berührt im bild am besten mit dem
schneebesen oder in kleinen löffel
[Musik]
und jetzt geht sich das über die
brownies drüber und verstreicht es dann
mit einem silikon pinseln
[Musik]
und den rand löse ich jetzt hier bin ich
schon im tortenring messer
ich kriege ich die brownies später
einfach heraus
[Musik]
und so lasse ich jetzt komplett abkühlen
und zeigt sich spätere manchester biere
die braun ist sind jetzt schön abgekühlt
und jetzt werde ich selber
durchschneiden und zwar schneide ich
selbst kleine quadrate war schon wieder
braun ja aber das ist ein richtig
leckeres saftiger augen
[Musik]
so der mora trägt jetzt ein kleines
stückchen ja aber nur ein kleines ja ja
kein großes
und ich finde er sieht schon so richtig
zünftig also richtig braun mäßig halt
saftig schokoladig klebrig lustig gleich
so ist gleich sagen wie immer sagt eine
ähnliche meinung wundervoll klasse alle
nachmachen
destani hat wirklich super gut wenn das
navi ich will ich sags mal so ironisch
ja etwas was mich da erwartet man im
fernsehen immer was probiert oder selber
gemacht hat muss er ja sagen es hat gut
gespielt
neben das net kann auch sagen das ist
verbesserungswürdig ist ja dann schneide
stehe daraus natürlich klasse
ich finde auch richtig gut und ich finde
es ist ein einfaches rezept was man gut
nachmachen kann und was auch eigentlich
jedem schmeckt bier schokolade und
netzwerke mag man kann ja auch man will
rein machen genau habe ich auch schon
erwähnt wurde dass man auch machen bei
machen kann
jetzt macht ist eine ganz tolle idee ich
würde zum beispiel interviews doch diese
diese backfest schokolade die stadt
darin ja aber ich will gegen weiss
reimann das wissen ja das kann es auch
mal hatte das doppel hat double
chocolate genau wie weißer gibt es auch
für uns genau das kann man gerne machen
und wenn ihr das nachmacht würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr mir ein foto auf
facebook oder instagram schickt und mich
da markiert damit ich mir das auch immer
schön anschauen kann
und das rezept gibt es auch celine was
mit ihren wie ist es überhaupt nächsten
mal wieder
[Musik]
haben jetzt die heilige familie gespielt
jetzt wieder zusammen doch das sagt man
nicht bekämpfen